Let's take a look at that last example in a little more detail.
What we would really like to do
is start at the top and call ourselves recursively
to optimize both children.
Once I figure out that 5 times 0 can be replaced by 0
and A can only be replaced by A
I rebuild my abstract syntax tree
and now I'm in a great position
to rewrite this to be just A.
So there's going to be
Step 1: recursive calls.
Step 2: Look for patterns.
And then, finally, Step 3: We are done.
In order for this to work out, our optimizer has to be recursive
just like our evaluator and our interpretor. This is not a coincidence.
Recursion--iteration--is really central to computer science.
It's fundamental.